we begin in the UK where the bank of
England has increased its Benchmark
interest rate by a quarter percentage
Point that's brought the rate to 4.25
while the inflation Target is two
percent this is the 11th consecutive Ray
tries and just a day after the
announcement that inflation has also
gone up and the U.S federal reserve put
its rate up the UK's February inflation
rate hit 10.4 percent driven by high
food and energy bills Paul Brennan has
more from London
the inflation that was announced on
Wednesday from 10.1 going up
unexpectedly to 10.4 percent rather
forcing the hand of the members of the
monetary policy Committee of the bank of
England when they made their decision
this morning
um I have to say there are some chinks
of hope uh in the predictions that the
bank of England are putting forward
they're saying for example well first of
all it was not a unanimous decision it
was seven to two in favor of increasing
the interest rates from four percent to
4.2 to 5 the other two members of the
monetary policy committee actually would
have preferred to keep interest rates
where they were so there are signs of of
a weakening resolve uh from the MPC
there the other thing is that the bank
of England no longer predicting that the
UK economy will go into recession there
is an expectation that the economy will
grow in inverted Commerce slightly over
the next year so a little glimmer of
hope there the other thing though is
that that they also expect Energy prices
or the energy price contribution to
inflation to turn negative during the
course of this year we of course had the
Ukraine war which bumped up the price of
energy namely Russian gas because of the
shortage of that that is expected to
come out of the inflationary pressure
over the next year those pressures
easing as people find Alternatives that
said though it is a still an increase
and there are concerns that as the banks
central banks around the world continue
to try to put the brakes on on inflation
it might spill over into a wider
recessionary pressure on the economy so
it's a very delicate balancing act that
these central banks are having to try
and tread
well Vicky price is an economist and
board member of the center for business
and economic research and she says the
latest interest rate hike wasn't a
surprise
the UK tends to follow what the Federal
Reserve does it has done in a number of
cases During the period of raising
interest rates so we've seen the last
few months
um but what could have been expected
just a few weeks ago would have been a
50 basis points increase and then maybe
the end of the cycle for interest rate
increases here in the UK I think there
was a similar discussion in in the US as
well but we've had the banking crisis of
sorts if you want to call it that the
the issues with a couple of uh you know
specialized Banks smaller banks in the
US which required government
intervention and you've had in Europe
Credit Suisse being bought by UBS and
the repercussions of that for other
banks in terms of Contagion on the share
prices is something which I think has
been taken into account and the reason
why we're seeing just a 0.25 percentage
increase here and in the US is partly
because of that and inflation has gone
up but it hasn't gone up only in
February in the UK it has gone having a
number countries in Europe as well and
that's probably why the European Central
Bank raised its own rates by 50 basis
points last week
the Swiss National Bank has also
increased its interest rate by half a
point Switzerland's key rate now stands
at 1.5 percent and the bank signaled
more hikes were possible the move comes
on the heels of turmoil in the Swiss
banking system
the state brokered a deal for banking
giant UBS to buy its troubled rival
Credit Suisse on Sunday